Guys, before we get into the actual zoom, what we're going to do, I want to talk really
quickly about best practices.
These are some things that if you will do these, you're going to increase your odds
and likelihood of getting the deal, okay?
You're not going to do these perfectly every time you're going to forget.
It's not going to be possible sometimes.
You're just going to do the best that you can given what you have to work with, okay?
I want to give you an example of where I learned this and how effective this was.
Back when I did door-to-door sales, they taught me, my managers at the time, they taught me
something really interesting.
They said the closer, the same thing that we're talking about here, but they taught
me some specific technical things to do.
They were like, hey, the closer you follow these specific things, the more likely you're
going to be to get the deal.
I became very rigid, very disciplined of doing these things because it always led to a sale,
okay?
Let me give you one example.
One thing that we always did and we were taught to do is when you go in the home, they said,
hey, when you go in the house, the first thing you're going to do is you're going to identify
the kitchen table.
You're going to go over to the kitchen table, you're going to take your binder and your
iPad, you're going to set it right at the kitchen table exactly where it's going to
be the best place to talk to both the husband and wife, okay?
Or both spouses or both partners, whatever.
The reason why you do this is because business is more likely to happen at the kitchen table
than at the couch.
And statistically speaking, if you sit at the couch, people are going to be relaxed,
they're going to be distracted, and they just think that they're talking or just talking
about the overall concept, but we're not getting down to business.
But when you sit at the kitchen table, people know that you mean business.
You're there to look at stuff, you're there to sign papers, you are doing a deal at the
kitchen table.
So since business happens at the kitchen table, not the couch, avoid the couch at all measures.
Go put the binder at the kitchen table and you will close more deals.
I did everything I could to make sure that was the case.
And I will tell you, there were some times they didn't have a kitchen table.
In a few instances, there was no kitchen table, so I did the best that I could.
There was a few times when they were insistent that we sit at the couch because the husband
was in a wheelchair or the kitchen table was full of stuff.
But even when it was full of stuff, I would just say, hey, it's fine, let's just push
some stuff to the side.
Like there was times there was mounds of stuff, right?
Disgusting, like syrup on the counter.
I would still sit at the kitchen table because I knew that's where deals happen.
So that's just one example.
So the equivalent of that with our deals are the following.
First of all, the time of day that you schedule the Zoom call.
It does matter.
And what happens is if you leave this up to chance and you just say, hey, business owner,
what time works for you?
That is a bad question because they're going to give you a terrible option.
They're going to say, well, I have a little lunch break here, here, here, and here.
Well, let me tell you about lunch breaks.
First of all, you know, as a business owner, they typically don't happen, number one.
Number two, the day gets going and the lunch break that was supposed to be an hour becomes
10 minutes, 15 minutes, 30 minutes, and they're rushed, right?
They're in the middle of the day, they're getting calls, they're getting inquiries.
They're trying to make money just like you.
And so, and on top of that, like imagine they're sitting at a diner, they're sitting at a fast
food restaurant and they're FaceTiming you from their phone.
Again, guys, that is not the best case scenario.
So here's a best practice as far as the time.
Try and do it first thing in the morning or late at night, okay?
That's what I have found to be the most effective and morning is definitely the best.
For me, it's best because I wake up, I'm fresh, I get a deal before I even go to the gym,
but also for them because they're not distracted, they're not getting hit up yet, so I like
early in the morning.
It's my favorite thing to do.
Secondly, I like to make sure to tell them, hey, be by a computer.
Now, the reason I justify it is I say, hey, I'm going to want to show you a couple things.
It's going to be really hard for you to see on your tiny phone.
So if you could be by a desktop, that would be perfect.
Or a laptop, be somewhere quiet by a laptop because I want to show you some things and
I'll usually tell them, hey, if we can do that, it's going to go a lot faster.
And really the reason why is I don't want them calling me from a cell phone where they're
going to be distracted, stuff's going to be coming in or they're going to feel like they
can just call me from a grocery parking lot or a gas station.
Guys, I've had somebody, because I didn't do this, they were going to buy dog food and
thought they could just FaceTime me or Zoom me, whatever.
So the first two things is the time.
I prefer mornings.
Second thing is make sure they're at a desktop or a laptop somewhere quiet.
Third thing is day of the week.
One thing that I have noticed is I've had really, really good luck getting people to
jump on the phone with me on weekends.
And you think about your business.
Typically, your customers are bugging you because they just don't feel like they can
or maybe they're not working.
In weekends, you can work on your business, not just in your business.
And so I've had really good luck on weekends.
Outside of that, I haven't really noticed a difference as far as days of the week.
So Monday, I do know Monday tends to be a lot busier, so that's one day I try to, if
possible, avoid.
But you know what?
I also want to get my deals on Monday.
So I still like to do sales calls on Mondays, but it does seem that it's harder to get
people to schedule on Monday.
It's through the weekend.
Maybe they forget.
So I like to do, you know, Tuesday through Saturday.
Saturday would be my best option.
I personally don't do sales calls on Sunday.
That's up to you.
But I do know that on weekends, people are going to be working more on their business
than in their business.
So guys, once again, do your best to follow those best practices.
Also one, maybe one last thing I'll note is sometimes business owners, they think that
when you say zoom, it's going to be some crazy thing, especially these older older people
that aren't used to it.
Just let them know.
So hey, I'm going to send you an email with a zoom link.
And that's another thing.
Don't text them a link or they're going to jump on their phone.
Say I'm going to email you a link to zoom.
And here's what's cool.
Mr. Business owner, Mrs. Business owner.
All you have to do is click on the link and it will automatically pop up because some
of them get scared and they're like, I don't know how to zoom and I hate technology.
Just reassure them that this is not a big deal.
Guys, follow those exactly best that you can.
Also understanding that sometimes those don't always make sense and it's always better to
just go for it and try to make everything perfect and I'll see you on the next video.